- Hello, hello, hello.
We're over a month into this quarantine
and it's a pretty stressful time,
like it's stressful for everybody,
not just us healthcare workers.
There's all sorts of new
challenges that we're facing
that we simply didn't expect,
so I wanted to make a video
where I can help you get
through this difficult time
as the best version of yourself.
I wanna give a huge thank you to Nike
for sponsoring this video,
where I'm gonna be giving
you some strategies
to optimize both your
physical and mental health.
In order for me to give
you comprehensive advice
on self care, we have to talk
about both the mind and body,
in fact, I don't like that
they're separate words,
it should be mind-body
'cause there's so intimately connected.
Any change you make to your mental health
will show physical effects,
any change you make to
your physical health,
will show mental effects.
First, let's focus up here.
The mindset that I want you
to have during quarantine,
when we're generally not moving
around much is on movement.
I want you motivated and
excited to go for that run,
to do that exercise regimen.
Let's get you started with these few tips.
Make tech your friend, there's
all sorts of meditation
and mindfulness apps that
can help you get motivated.
What I like to do is
listen to the Nike Run Club
Audio Guided Runs, they have athletes
and motivational speakers
like Coach Bennett,
to really boost my mood and my
performance at the same time.
Stay on routine.
For many of us, jobs
give our day structure
and with so many people being out of work
or their work being disrupted,
it's very easy to go to sleep at any time,
wake up at any time of the day,
but that actually adds a
layer of chaos to your life
that your mind and body both don't like.
So create a routine and stick to it,
plus, you'll make your life easier.
Oh, it's five o'clock, gotta exercise
'cause that's just what I do.
Understand willpower.
Too many people assume
they have to be motivated
in order to get an action,
action proceeds willpower,
you need to take that first step,
do the first exercise class
in order for you to get some
willpower for the next time,
doesn't have to be anything huge,
just something small that you
can check off as a success
in order to refill the willpower tank.
Stay social, physical distancing
does not mean social isolation.
Humans are social beings, we
crave that type of connection,
FaceTime a friend, go on a Skype meeting
with all of your family
members to talk some drama,
go on a real date, take it seriously,
don't just get on a couch in pajamas,
get a meal, get all dressed up.
Celebrate human resilience.
Humans are great at
bouncing back from adversity
and a pandemic like this is
the definition of adversity.
In fact, what we've seen
with scientific research
is evidence for post traumatic growth.
So while most humans,
when they go through something traumatic,
their baseline drops and then
they can bounce back to normal
once the adversity ends but
in post traumatic growth,
you actually see this baseline drop off,
and then come up even higher.
So we can come out of this
pandemic as better humans,
those who appreciate
the things we once took
for granted, let's do that.
Get physical.
(grunting)
Folks, you gotta keep your body in motion,
you gotta stay moving.
I know it's hard now during quarantine,
when gyms are closed and
perhaps running outside
isn't so safe, you still have to do it,
otherwise you're gonna
develop aches, pains,
your moods gonna suffer.
Let's start with something
I've fallen in love with,
online exercise classes courtesy
of the Nike Training Club.
- [Instructor] Your head, hips and ankles
should all be in a nice straight line,
sit back into your hips
and lower yourself down
so your upper legs are
parallel to the ground.
Stay relaxed in Child's Pose.
- You have to make due with what you have
and I have a stationary
bike, this is perfect
for getting a high intensity
interval workout it.
For those of you who don't know,
an HIIT workout is when
we alternate long periods
of low intensity exercise,
followed by short bursts
of high intensity.
Low intensity is slow, low effort,
high intensity is like all outbursts
for a short period of time
and trust me in like 20, 30 minutes,
you can get a solid workout
in, where you're burning fat,
maintaining muscle, cardio,
strength training all in one
and you don't need a
stationary bike for that.
You could go on a treadmill,
you could even do it in your hallway.
(lively music)
(whistle blowing)
Everything I'm explaining to
you is about being adaptable,
leaning into uncertainty and
making use of what you have.
I know there's gonna be people
out there that are saying,
"Look Mike, I appreciate
doing squats at home
"but I need weights."
You make use with what
you have, what do I have?
- [Dog] Nice.
- Okay, I'm obviously
joking, don't use your dog.
You could use other things
this way, like sandbags.
I have a sandbag to hold down the sea sand
and I have dog hair on me.
Kettlebell swings, this
is actually pretty heavy
and it's a good workout.
Okay, I get it, not
everyone has a sandbag,
almost everyone has a book bag
that you can load up with
heavy stuff, kettlebell swings.
You see what I'm saying?
Not everyone needs fancy gym equipment
in order to get a good workout.
I'm out of breath already.
Even though this is a quarantine,
we're in a pandemic, you
still can have a good time
and stay fit, at the end of the day,
I'm a doctor and doctors
write a lot of prescriptions,
but prescriptions and
all medical treatments
need to be individualized,
so here's your prescription,
a prescription for play.
(soft piano music)
(bright instrumental music)
Thanks Nike for sponsoring this video.